Musik Liebe Leute, zu der neuenesrand es halte. Klagen kamen da die Knappen, Banner tragend ihnen prangte der ... Lass nochmal neue Frage, ich hab wieder keinen Bock mehr auf diese Scheisse, dass du hier ständig mit mir reinredest. Und ich dir, das ist scheisse. Wir haben heute wieder Skype. Weißt du, du hast eben etwas Uncooles gemacht. Und ich habe nebenbei halt etwas Cooles reingesprochen. Ja, aber es ist einfach nicht dasselbe. Wenn wir uns gegenüber sitzen, dann sehen wir uns, dann ist eine gewisse Körperlichkeit einfach da. Da ist eine gewisse Feuchtigkeit einfach in der Luft. Und hier ist es immer so, du fängst irgendwas an, dann rede ich rein, dann redest du rein, dann ist das wieder, ich habe Mathen gemacht. Ich hasse es gleich habe das klasse physik kann ich physik bei dir abschreiben bitte ich habe ohne witz ich habe physik nicht gemacht ich habe bio nicht weißt du was ich mache mal einen video anruf nein wir machen keinen video anruf das klappt nicht weil das ist komplett versetzt und es ist noch eine weitere grössere problematik mega unc uncool. Wieso denn? Das ist doch nicht so uncool. Herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO mit einem ... Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Das Podcast UFO. Sie hören heute ein musikalisches Intro, vorgetragen von Jeff Francesco und Florian Webel. Drei ... Warte. Warte, wie fangen wir an? Es ist halt schwierig mit dem Delay, es ist total schwierig gerade. Es ist extrem schwierig. Okay, drei, vier. Hey, liebe Leute, während Florentin noch nonchalant im Hintergrund weiterspielt, begrüsse ich euch zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Heute dabei Knaller Gags, unsere tolle neue Rubrik, das Spektakel von Ich glaub, mich tritt ein Pferd und Florentin wird kontinuierlich mit seinen tollen Gitarrenstücken die Sendung bereichern. Ich bin manchmal, du sagst nonchalant, aber ich bin tatsächlich relativ häufig mehr Chalant, als man denkt. Man sieht nicht und denkt, oh, das ist ein ziemlich nonchalanter Typ, aber innerlich bin ich Chalant wie die Sau. Wir machen heute mal Skype mit Videoanruf, weil wir finden, Skype mit Ton hat schon so gut geklappt, Da müssen wir noch ein bisschen was drauflegen, die Bandbreite noch ein bisschen mehr strapazieren, ein bisschen breiter machen die Bandbreite. Die ist noch nicht breit genug, das ist zu schmal. Jede Woche ein Stück besser, das ist unser Credo. Du trinkst einen Tee, sehe ich gerade, in deiner tollen Wohnung. Kannst du mal ganz kurz mir deinen Fisch zeigen, wo der ist, den will ich gerne mal sehen. Ohne Scheiß, geht auf gar keinen Fall, dann muss das Interface, wie soll das gehen? Du bist mit dem exakt gleichen Setting angeschlossen wie ich. Nee, ich habe ein Laptop. Du weißt, dass es nicht funktioniert. Ja, aber du... Ich kann dir kurz mal... Weil ich zeige dir mein Schwert. Komischer Euphemismus, aber... Hier, guck mal, wie ist denn mein Schwert da hinten? Hier, wie es in meinem Schreibtisch steckt? Ja, das habe ich schon mal gesehen. Sieht gut aus, ne? Schön, du wohnst schön. Was ist denn das für ein Kabel, das über deine Tür hängt? Das ist das Ethernet-Netzwerk-Kabel, falls WLAN abbricht. Das Telefonmask, das Starkstromkabel, das die Stadt mit dem Kraftwerk verbindet und es genau durch dein Wohnzimmer führt. Ich bin hier eingezogen und habe gesagt, wenn ich einmal eine Runde Starcraft spiele und die Internetverbindung bricht ab, dann lege ich mir ein fucking Kabel durch die Wohnung in meinen Rechner und genau das ist passiert und seitdem ist es auch nicht besser geworden. Was war Starcraft nochmal genau von den ganzen Spielen, die es da jetzt gibt? Starcraft ist das mit diesem kleinen... Nee, was ist denn dieses wirbelige Spiel, dieses wirbelige Spiel, wo du diese ganz vielen kleinen Wirbel hast, diese ganz vielen kleinen wuseligen Menschen... Bayblade. Diese ganzen kleinen wuseligen Menschen, die da irgendwie sich abfacken, also ganz viele von oben so eine Draufsicht. Ist das Dota oder? Ja, das könnte schon Starcraft sein. Ja, könnte Starcraft sein. Also Starcraft zwei sind mehr Figuren als Dota zwei. Ich trinke hier, guck mal, ich habe hier einen Krupp. Was ist denn das für ein Gesäff? Das ist Schwibschwab. Das ist Schwibschwab Zero. Habe ich mir heute mal gegönnt. Ich dachte, ne, das ist Schwibschwab. Aber es gibt auch Cola. Es gibt auch Metzomix, es gibt auch Spezi. Müssten wir nicht. Wir sind gar nicht in der Lage, dass wir uns immer da rausreden müssen. Wir können knallharte Schleichwerbung machen.
Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, von diesen ganzen Zero-Produkten finde ich diese Cola-orangenen Mischgetränke noch am besten. Ich finde, da schmeckt man es nicht so raus, den Unterschied. Bei Cola oder so, Fanta, gerade Sprite ist, finde ich, sehr hart, da kommt der Süßstoff sehr raus, aber bei diesen Mischgetränken, finde ich, da klappt es noch am besten. Das ist meine Meinung. Ich wollte ja heute eigentlich das Thema Behaglichkeit anbieten mal.
Einfach weil ich mir dachte, komm, ich habe mir mal hier ein Glas mit Eiswürfeln gemacht, weil ich es kann.
Ich habe auch Eiswürfel, aber die sind schon geschmolzen.
Aber man kann sich einfach, Eiswürfel sind exakt geil.
Es gibt geil, es gibt zu geil und es gibt nicht so geil.
Aber Eiswürfel sind komplett durchdacht, komplett gut, funktionieren auf allen Ebenen, in Getränken, kann man so sagen.
Und tatsächlich, ich habe in München, in der WG, in der ich gewohnt habe, die erste WG, da war echt die, mein Mitwohner hat gesagt, es ist mir scheissegal, wenn uns die Milch ausgeht, das Mehl ausgeht, das einzige, was wir immer haben müssen, sind Eiswürfel.
Wenn du die Eiswürfel nimmst, füll das Wasser nach, damit wir immer Eiswürfel haben. Das war die oberste Priorität und das hat tatsächlich mein Leben einfach massiv gebessert, immer Eiswürfel zu haben. Normalerweise sagt man sich, jetzt ein Kaipi, jetzt ein American Summer, jetzt ein White Russian oder was auch immer, jetzt irgend so was haben, aber dann muss man erst mal wieder acht Stunden lang sich ins Bett legen und auf die Eiswürfel warten. Das ist auch diese Geschichte, die Olli Schulz immer erzählt, dass er halt nur einen Luxuswunsch hat, und zwar eine Eiswürfelmaschine in dem Kühlschrank zu haben.
Und da habe ich mal geguckt, ob es das auch, weil diese Maschine, die da drin integriert ist, muss es ja auch separat kaufbar geben.
Und die gibt es separat kaufbar, ist aber wahnsinnig teuer. Die kostet irgendwie 500 Euro oder so für eine Maschine, die Eis gefriert und es so ein bisschen klein macht.
Aber das würde ganz gut zu deinem Lebenswandel passen. Ich habe das Gefühl, du betrittst gerade so eine neue Lebensphase. Man macht ja immer so Lebensphasen durch und man sagt ja so in Sieben dann. Das Leben verändert sich immer alle sieben Jahre. Das ist interessant, ja. Null bis sieben bist du Kind, dann sieben bis vierzehn ist so Anfang Pubertät erwachsen werden, vierzehn bis einundzwanzig ist dann nochmal so richtig hardcore erwachsen werden. Das spricht übrigens auch genauso für unsere Folgen. Also die ersten sieben Folgen waren noch sehr kindlich, danach war es ein bisschen pubertär, experimentell, wir sind uns gegenseitig auf den Sack gegangen, wir waren sehr Stimmungsschwankungen, die Folgen waren sehr schwankend, Penis, viele Peniswitze, viel Akne auch, also man hat es nicht gesehen, weil wir im Podcast sind, aber wir haben unfassbar Hautprobleme gehabt zu der Zeit. Und dann ging es halt, mittlerweile geht es ein bisschen bergauf und wir werden so ein bisschen erwachsener. Genau, und du bist jetzt gerade 21 Jahre alt geworden. Das heißt, für dich beginnt ein neue Tür. Happy Birthday to me, YouTube. Und deswegen geht eine neue Lebensphase los und ich bemerke das so ein bisschen. Ich kenne dich jetzt schon seit zweieinhalb Jahren und ich merke schon, da tut sich was im Karton. Da langsam beim Stefan, da wird da die ersten Haare fangen anzuspriessen, wo vorher keine waren. Ja, das ist echt so. Ich habe unsere Maskenbildnerin, unserer Sendung, wo wir arbeiten, für, die hat nämlich gesagt, dass mir ein Bart stehen würde. Und wenn jemand sagt, wenn jemand sagen kann, dass dir etwas im Gesicht steht, ist es die fucking Maskenbildnerin, die muss es wissen, das ist ihr Job, das ist so, als wenn ein Feuerwehrmann zu dir sagt, deine Wohnung fängt, steht in Flammen. Ja, das ist immer nur das Gleiche. Sie kennen sich aus, wunderbar, Hätte ich jetzt nicht so gesehen, aber von mir aus, ich vertraue Ihnen.
Überall schreien die Menschen, überall Blut. Ja, und genauso ist das mit einer Massenbildnerin, wenn sie dir sagt, das steht dir, dann sagt er mal ein bisschen Bart. Könnte aber natürlich auch beissende Ironie gewesen sein, Stefan, damit musst du immer rechnen. Ja, ich kann mit Ironie, glaube ich, ein bisschen umgehen. Apropos Lebenswandel. Das ist so, wie wenn du das unbeliebte Kind aus der Schule auf deine Party eingeladen hast und gesagt hast, hey, bereite doch mal ein Gedicht für Nina vor vielleicht, du würdest dich doch freuen, für Stefan vor, lest doch Stefan mal auf der Party ein Gedicht vor, da würden sich alle freuen. Das sind dann die Art von Ratschlägen, die man dann nochmal kritisch hinterfragen sollte. Und genauso die Maskenbilderin, die sagt so, hey, so ein Scheitel und so ein Schnurrbart wird dir total gut stehen. Zu ihrer Kollegin. Das ist dann der wichtige Punkt. Das Kaisers schöne Kleider. Zieh doch mal einfach gar nichts an, sagte die Kostümbildnerin und ich tat es. Märchen, Märchengags, warum nicht, ich weiß nicht. Obwohl mein Märchengag letztens extrem schlecht angekommen ist. Die Leute hassen Märchen. Märchen sind nicht mehr zeitgemäss.
Welcher denn? Welchen meinst du denn? Ich wünsche mir einen... Du kannst nicht so im Raum stehen lassen, meinen Gag von damals, wenn du dann einfach... Ich will ja nicht über gelöschte Gags sprechen eigentlich. Irgendwann bringe ich mal ein Buch raus mit allen Tweets, die ich gelöscht habe, einfach um zu sehen, was ich euch eigentlich erspart habe die ganzen Jahre. Man sagt ja immer, oh toll, aber wenn ihr mal wüsstet, was da eigentlich wirklich in den Untiefen meiner Gag-Dokumente
sich verbergen würde, da würdet ihr kreischend aufschreien.
Es sind ja nur die schlechten Gags im
Augen aller, also in
der Geschmacksrichtung
eines Konglomerats.
Vielleicht trifft es ja manche Menschen ja
total ins Humorzentrum. Deswegen
ist es ja bei Spotify auch immer so interessant, dass
nicht unbedingt die Top 3 der beliebtesten
Lieder einer Band oder eines Acts
unbedingt die besten sein müssen, die die jetzt am besten
Vielen Dank. total ins Humorzentrum. Deswegen ist es ja bei Spotify auch immer so interessant, dass nicht unbedingt die Top drei der beliebtesten Lieder einer Band oder eines Acts unbedingt die besten sein müssen, die dir jetzt am besten gefallen. Also muss man sich eigentlich immer alle Lieder von allen Alten anhören. Aber ich finde, es ist eine schöne Metapher, weil auch die schlechten Seiten seines Charakters zeigt man ja oft nur wenigen Menschen, wohingegen die guten Facetten zeigt man ja allen. Also meine schlechten Gags kriegen wirklich nur meine Hardcore-Fans mit, die ständig an meiner Timeline hängen und alle drei Sekunden die Fraschen. Aber da sagst du doch so eine Darsteller-Künstler-Art raus, weil die meisten Leute können sich ja gar nicht entscheiden, wann sie ihre gute und wann sie ihre schlechte Arten zeigen. Doch man kann natürlich schon, wenn man mit einer anderen Person zu tun hat. Da muss aber so reflektiert sein zu wissen, was seine schlechte Charaktereigenschaften sind. Man setzt halt eine Maske auf. Naja. Nein, ich glaube, einfach sagen wir, nicht zu verstellen, glaube ich, holt schon deine schlechten Charaktereigenschaften raus. Dass du halt anfängst zu nügen oder Dinge anders so darzustellen. Dann gehst du von dir aber so aus, dass du unverstellt schon mal ein Riesenarschloch bist. Ja, du wirst dich ja nicht verstellen, um noch größeres Arschloch zu sein. Natürlich bist du das grösstmögliche Arschloch, wenn du dich am wenigsten verstellst. Was glaubst du? Weil du würdest dich dann natürlich nicht so verstellen, dass du ein Arschloch bist. Doch klar, ist doch logisch. Glaubst du, der Durchschnittsmensch ist ein Arschloch? Also der rohe Mensch, an dem noch nicht irgendwie sozial gefühlmässig durch Gruppendynamik was verändert wurde. Glaubst du, der Durchschnittsmensch ist einfach ein extremes Arschloch?
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt aber auch Facetten des Arschlochseins, die erst durch Kultur und Anpassungsfähigkeit erfasst werden. Aber an sich ist es schon mal ein Arschloch auf jeden Fall. Ich habe nämlich was echt Lustiges gestern gesehen auf Galileo. Ich habe mal wieder bei Galileo reingesappt, dachte ich mir, ey, kannst du mal geile Wasserrutschen-Testen noch mal reinziehen? Und dann haben die mal was Tolles gemacht. Die haben wirklich so eine Parallelgesellschaft besucht. Von Arschlöchern, wo sich hundert Arschlöcher Deutschlands einfach zusammengezogen haben, gesagt haben, wir leben in einem grossen Arschloch-Konglomerat. Wie muss die Welt aussehen? Ja, genau. Nennt sich Bielefeld, könnte man jetzt einen Gag machen, sowas. Könnte man machen, aber habe ich nicht gemacht, weil dieser lokale Humor passt einfach nicht in den Podcast. Jetzt könnte man sagen, Bielefeld gibt es nicht. Das ist das Uncoolste der Welt. Das sind genau die gleichen Leute, die auch zumindest sagen. Weiß nicht. Jedenfalls ist es so, Galileo hat so eine Alternativgesellschaft besucht, so eine Utopia-mässige Gesellschaft und deren Experiment war halt, dass sie ohne Regeln leben, dass ganz viele Menschen da leben ohne Regeln, es keine Regeln gibt. Und ein Grossteil dieses Beitrags ging dann darum, einen Mann zu zeigen, der an einem Feuerwerk teilgenommen hat. Also ganz viele Menschen leben in einer Gesellschaft, es gibt keine Regeln. Und ich fand es interessant, was machen Menschen in einer Gesellschaft, wo es keine Regeln gibt? Die Antwort, Feuerwerk. Den ganzen Tag, jeden Tag. Den ganzen Tag ein Feuerwerk. Sondern bis sie ihre Ressourcen aufgebraucht haben, gibt es jeden Tag Feuerwerk. Würde ich aber auch machen. Und dann gab es da diesen durchschnittlichsten, repräsentativsten Menschen, der einfach so einen Beutel hochgehalten hat, wo ganz viele diese kleinen Feuerwerkskörper drin sind, diese kleinen Pyramiden, wo Sachen rauskommen. Weiß nicht, bist du nur Knallfreak an Silvester? Ich bin total drin, ich habe genau Vorstellungen, ja, Chicago. Und dann gibt es halt diese kleinen durchsichtigen Beutel, wo dann irgendwie die Knallfrösche drin sind und die kleinen Feuerteufelchen, so halt so ganz süßen Kindersachen. Und er hat diesen Beutel und hat der Journalistin gefragt, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit diesem Beutel voller Knallkörper? Und es war diese Gesellschaft ohne Regeln, also das Rulebook lag im Papierkorb, kann man sagen, und er hat diesen Beutel genommen. So wie bei Stefan Tütze zu Hause, ja. Und er hat diesen Beutel genommen und einfach ins Feuer geworfen. Und danach ging er auch so, okay, geil, der Mensch ohne Regeln schmeißt ein Paket voller Kinderknallkörper offensichtlich einfach ins Feuer. Ja, du brauchst auch Regeln erst nur ab dem ersten Arschloch. Bis zum ersten Arschloch geht alles gut, aber je größer deine Gruppe wird, irgendwann kommt einfach ein Arschloch random dazu und dann brauchst Regeln. Alter, Hanno, ernsthaft, du kannst nicht schon wieder die Leiter klauen, das kann nicht sein, und dann brauchst du Regeln. Die Leiter kriegt Dünnstack immer Johanna. Das funktioniert einfach nicht, du brauchst Regeln. Wann verstößt du gegen Regeln? Naja, was heißt Regeln? Was war die krasseste Regel, die du schon mal verstossen hast? Ich bin schon in diesem Interviewmodus drin, merkst du, weil ich mich auf diese Folge wie ein Interview vorbereitet habe. Oh, Spoiler, Spoiler! Spoiler! Spoiler! Ich sag nicht mehr! Nein! Spoiler! Spoiler! Der darfst nicht spoilern! Aber wir können ja sagen, dass ein Gast abgesagt hat, spontan, weil er bei einer cooleren Sendung ist, zu Gast heute. Das kann man sagen. Ich gehe ab und zu bei Rot über die Ampel. Weil ich manchmal auch gerne Regeln brechen möchte. Wurde es schon mal erwischt, einer, als ich noch studiert habe, einer unserer Philosophie-Master, der uns, der Dozent war, der Master. Alles, was aus diesem Studiengang jetzt fing, ist so cool. Master Roman, der uns gesagt, dass er mal nachts in München unterwegs war und da war dann, die Ampeln laufen dann immer noch weiter und dann war die Ampel rot und einige Leute standen vor der roten Ampel, obwohl überhaupt kein Auto weit und breit zu sehen war. Und es kam weit und breit kein Auto, aber die Leute standen trotzdem an der Ampel. Und dann kam er zu den Leuten und hat gesagt, es waren offensichtlich Touristen, dann hat er gesagt, don't do that, only Germans do that. Und dann ist er über die rote Ampel gegangen. Und das war so der Badass-Move und natürlich alle Philosophie-Studierenden sagen, dafür habe ich Philosophie studiert, genau für diesen coolen Moment, jetzt, dafür und dass ich immer direkt eine Baskenmütze tragen darf und Rotwein trinke, yes, endlich. Und dann dachte ich mir, da ist schon irgendwas dran, wie weit sollte eigentlich blindes Regelgehorchen gehen? Und ich bin jemand, der einfach Regelgehorcht liebend gerne, der einfach sagt, rote Ampel, nö, muss ich nicht rübergehen, muss ja nicht sein, und dann lieber warte. Aber manchmal versuche ich auch absolut, die Regeln zu brechen. Ja, aber Regeln brechen ist manchmal halt auch dumm, wie dieser Beitrag zeigt, dass wenn Menschen keine Regeln haben, sie einfach so ein Feuerwäcksding einfach in die Flammen werfen. Das ist natürlich der, das ist der Supergau. Und überall stehen Menschen, das ist halt in der Menschenmasse. Das ist der Supergau, ja. Der ist einfach dämlich, Menschen sind dann einfach vielleicht dumm. Deshalb brauchen die Regeln, um so ein bisschen ein strukturiertes Leben zu führen? Bist du ein Regeltyp, welche Regeln hast du schon mal verstoßen? Ich bin auch mal in eine rotere Ampel gelaufen, das habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, glaube ich. Da sind dann die Polizisten hinter mir hergelaufen, weil ich Kopfhörer im Moor hatte, habe ich nicht gehört, dass sie hinter mir hergelaufen sind. Und es ist so eine wilde Verfolgungsjagel mit Blaulicht entstanden. Die größte Straftaten, die wir hier getan haben. Aber da können wir noch mehr über unser Thema der Sendung reden, Versäumnisse. Ich glaube, ich habe massive Steuerversäumnisse. Wollte jetzt noch irgendwie die Kurve kriegen. Oh ja, ich auch. Ich glaube, ich bin ein massiver Steuerhinterzieher, ohne das zu wissen, weil ich es einfach nicht durchblicke. Wir beide arbeiten irgendwie frei, Mischungen aus frei und fest und sind Studenten, du nicht, ich schon und weiss nicht genau, was da gerade läuft. Und weiss auch nicht, wie viel ich arbeiten darf und ich glaube, das geht einfach alles schief.
Ich glaube, es wird mal einen grossen Moment in meinem Leben geben, wo ich einmal ganz laut sage, ach so, das wusste ich aber nicht und dann direkt ins Gefängnis gehe, instant, so genau nachdem ich diesen Satz gesagt habe, Irgendwann sagt, Entschuldigen Sie, Herr Günther, das ist Ihnen schon klar, dass die Steuerabschluss... Dass sie nicht Günther heissen, sondern Will.
Was? Das? Das ist mir neu. Ja, dann, ja okay, ab jetzt zahle ich Steuern, okay, ab jetzt mache ich es. Und ich glaube, das wird nicht gut enden, also gar nicht. Aber zum Beispiel Versäumnisse, so eine gewisse Kleinkriminalität muss man ja schon an den Tag gelegt haben. Ich habe letztens mit meiner Mutter geredet und es ist ja ganz toll, dass sich irgendwann diese ganzen erzieherischen Massnahmen in Luft auflösen. Und also natürlich, wenn dein Kind was anstellt und Verbrechen begeht, dann musst du das natürlich ausschimpfen und sagen, es geht nicht. Aber natürlich aus einer erzieherischen Metaperspektive kann man sagen, es ist schon eine gute Erfahrung, wenn ein Kind auch mal geklaut hat und erwischt wurde. Das heißt, jeder sollte mal ein bisschen Kleinkriminalität betreiben, aber in dem Moment musst du natürlich dagegen sein. Aber das hat meine Mutter so gemacht, so von wegen, ja, ich glaube, das war schon okay, dass jeder von euch mal so ein bisschen irgendwie mit dem Gesetz aneinander geraten ist. Ausser dir, Florentin, du hast ja nie was angestellt. Weil die haben ein bisschen Angst, dass es irgendwann zu doppelter Erstecke zurückkommt. Wo selbst meine Mutter gesagt hat, dass ich so uncool war, dass ich selbst meiner Mutter zu brav war. Wo ich sagte so, okay, mega dis einfach. Ja, wir haben mal, wo wir gerade bei Dingen, ich habe auch nie sowas gemacht. Und einmal habe ich halt so eine Gummischnur, so eine extrem harte Gummischnur. Von der einen Strassenseite war die andere gespannt. Das sind die coolsten Geschichten, fangen mit einer extrem dünnen Gummischnur an. Mit einer extrem harten Gummischnur, also das ist schon huiuiui. Und die habe ich von einer Strassenseite über die andere gespannt, dass man die nicht gesehen hat. Hast du ein viergängiges Mädchen geköpft? Und Fahrradfahrer werden einfach geköpft worden. Ja klar. Und da dachte ich mir dann irgendwann, okay, gut. Es ist weder lustig noch irgendwie bringt es die Gesellschaft weiter, es ist nicht wirklich ein Graffiti, wo irgendwie was draufsteht, wie man die Welt verbessern kann, es ist einfach ein uncooler Prank, der tödlich enden kann.
Und dann habe ich es einfach wieder eingerollt und dachte mir, ja, damit habe ich glaube ich alles aufgeholt.
Aber jetzt ganz kurz, sag mir bitte, wie viele, also versuch es auf die Minute oder Sekunde genau zu benennen, wie lange hing diese Schnur? Wie lange hat es gedauert, bis sie der Ratte... Eine Minute, eine Minute, 37, dachte ich mir. Eine Minute, wo einfach klein Stefan in seinem wahrscheinlich viel zu grossen Anorak mit Ohrenwärmern steht da draußen an der B822 irgendwie in neue Bruchstecken und denkt sich, ist es der beste Prank der Welt oder der schlechteste Prank der Welt? Und weiss nicht, ob er sich jetzt das Feuchten lachen soll, steht er wahrscheinlich direkt daneben, sodass jeder sofort merkt und denkt sich dann irgendwann, nee, weißt du was? Er steht direkt daneben mit so einem grossen, Achtung, Schnurschild. Ganz kurz, wir überlegen ja immer, was wir für unseren YouTube-Channel machen würden, aber das würde ich gerne machen. Einfach nur Stefan Titzel zeigen, wie er so eine Schnur aufbaut, dann eine Minute 37 wartet und dann wieder abbaut. Und das ist einfach das Wahse. Das erinnert mich auch gerade an deine erste April-Geschichte, wo du halt diese gebrochene Scheibe an den Ofen geklebt hast und es auch wieder abgemacht hast. Wie wir sind diese einsteigenden Ereignisse in unserem Leben, das ist so uncool. Das sind diese Pranks, wo man dann denkt, aber wir waren anscheinend damals schon so reflektiert, dass wir wussten, dass es nicht lustig wird mehr. Wir wussten, dass wir nichts mehr, wir kriegen die Kurve nicht mehr, haben es gelassen. Ich freue mich wirklich auf den Moment, wenn ich im Sterben liege und mein Leben an mir vorbeizieht und Momente wie, ich kratze den Pranknagel wieder von der Scheibe ab, ohne dass der Prank funktioniert hat. Das sind die Momente, schamvoll, einfach wieder die Mausefalle wieder aufklappen und entschärfen und sagen, nee, ich glaube, Oma, Oma, hätte ich es doch nicht ins Bett legen sollen und wieder gehen einfach. Genau, wo dann dein blasser Leichenkörper noch rot wird vor Scham. Ja, genau. Und sich so ein leichtes Lächeln auf dem Freit macht. Ich glaube, Scham wird die letzte Emotion meines Lebens sein. Wird Scham sein. Auch ein interessantes Thema, Beerdigung. Wie machen wir unsere Beerdigung? Vielleicht mal nächste Folge. Nee, immer nächste Folge. Wir haben nächste Folge den Gast. Beerdigung schreibe ich mir mal auf gerade. Das ist ein interessantes Thema. Du siehst gerade auch, weil wir zum ersten Mal einen Videochat machen, dass ich mir wirklich aufschreibe, dass wir es machen. Ja, ich habe auch immer noch eine Klammer offen, die ich mit der Anmoderation eröffnet habe und immer noch nicht abgeschlossen habe. Aber das ist doch gut. Das ist doch immer gut, dass wir ein bisschen abschweichen. Naja, aber irgendwo muss er zurückkommen. Dass wir mal ein bisschen Freestyle. Das wird man nicht an Sendungsbuch halten, dass wir jede Woche zehn Tage lang vorbereiten. Ja, ja, ja. Also, Stefan ist 21 geworden, damit beginnt ein neuer Lebenserfahrt.
Happy Birthday!
Wo führt das hin? Ja, wie wird das sich verändern, wie wird das sich als Mensch verändern? Er trägt seit neuerdings Bart. Aber nicht so richtig. Ich habe ihn vor zwei Tagen in einem relativ ernsten Gespräch mal zur Seite genommen und gesagt so, hey, lass das mal lieber mit dem Bart. Und? Das ist vielleicht nicht so dein. Wer hat sich danach rasiert, aber sofort. Er kam nach Hause und hat sich sofort rasiert, weil ich nur darauf warte, bis jemand sagt, ah ah, und dann gehe ich sofort nach Hause und mache das weg. Wenn jemand sagt, das T-Shirt sieht nicht gut aus, dann war ich auch sofort, schmeiße ich es weg. Ich habe mir jetzt tatsächlich, also, wer sagt mal Versäumnisse, und da ist bei mir ein großes Thema natürlich Mode. Also Mode habe ich wahnsinnig viele Versäumnisse gemacht, und es ist ein Problem, wenn du zu einem gewissen Alter nicht ein Ziel gefunden hast. Ganz kurz, ich finde Versäumnisse setzt voraus, dass du irgendwann mal die Kurve gekriegt hast. Und ich möchte nicht, dass du bei diesem Thema denkst, dass du die Kurve gekriegt hast. Ich trage gerade Jogginghose und ein Rocket Beans T-Shirt, das ist gerade mein Ensemble. Ah, okay, nochmal, wie gesagt, wir gucken uns gerade an, kriegt ihr alles nicht mit, das alles ist gerade in eurem Kopf und er hat ein weisses Rocket Beans T-Shirt an, hat eine Jogginghose an, eine dunkle, kann man sagen, so geht man durch, er trägt keine Schuhe und keine Socken, gar nichts, gar nichts, okay. Und das Problematische, sage ich mal, an Lebensentwürfen sind ja immer die harten Brüche, Also wenn du von jung auf irgendwie ständig, dann kaufst du dir mal eine etwas coolere Jacke, eine etwas coolere Hose und dann geht das so langfristig rein. Aber wenn du merkst, oh shit, ich bin 24, sitze jetzt hier, weine in meinem Müsli und habe einen schlechten Modegeschmack, du kannst, du hast ja auch nicht das Selbstbewusstsein, ab morgen einfach irgendwie in coolen Klamotten rumzulaufen, weil dann alle sagen würden, was ist denn da los? Und dann ziehst du auf etwas Aufmerksamkeit, worauf du keine Aufmerksamkeit ziehen möchtest, weil du kannst jetzt nicht einfach irgendwie. Ja, das dauert mir zu lange. Ich gucke, wie ich aussehe. Wir werden mal kurz, wir werden mal kurz. Oh, die Jogginghose, aber die graue, die kurze Jogginghose. Ja, und Socken dazu und natürlich ein Applaus-T-Shirt, wo ich das Motiv nicht kenne. Ich kenne das Motiv. Also das aber ganz ganz kurz, das heißt, du trägst schon mal doppelt so viele Klagenstücke wie ich. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du eine Unterhose an hast. Na klar. Die habe ich nicht an, das heißt, ich habe nur T-Shirt und Jogginghose an. Kannst du das mal zeigen, dass du keine Unterhose an hast? Nein, auf keinen Fall, nein, auf keinen Fall. Er hat sich wieder hingesetzt, er hat es nicht gemacht. Das heißt, du wirst schon mal doppelt so gut ausgeschaut. Du würdest in einem Strip-Poker- schon mal doppelt so lange durchhalten wie ich. Ich habe auch eine Brille auf. Ich habe auch eine Brille auf. Ah, ich glaube, Brille zählt nicht bei. Weiß ich nicht. Das ist dann wieder klassisch bei Strippoker, wo die Mädchen dann anfangen, die Ohrringe rauszunehmen, wo ich dann sage, fuck it, wir haben Regeln, Melissa, wir haben Regeln aufgeschrieben, sei nicht der Typ. Du kannst nicht deinen Gebiss rausnehmen, Melinda. Das geht nicht. Genau, ist das eine Hüfte? Verdammt nochmal. Du kannst deine Perücke nicht abnehmen, nur weil du eine Chemo hast. Das geht nicht. Das einzige Mädchen mit einem Holzbein geht völlig selbstbewusst in die Strip-Hooker-Runde und sagt, okay Jungs, lasst uns loslegen. Auf jeden Fall, das geht nicht. Man kann nicht die Ohrringe ausziehen, es funktioniert nicht. Fick dich, Melissa, ohne Witz, fick dich. Müssen wir alle mal einladen. Melissa, Gizmo, diese ganzen Namen, die wir immer wieder aufnehmen. Benno, Bafolev, Schmiesel, Wolkenköpfchen, die müssen alle mal kommen. Du hast eben mal unseren YouTube-Channel, du hast immer noch nicht viel Circle gebracht. Ja, ich weiß schon. Du hast immer noch nicht in einer Circle gebracht, was du gerade gesagt hast. Lebenswandel. Wir waren gerade beim Thema Lebenswandel. Du hast gesagt, ich habe jetzt ein Bad. Ich trinke auch neuerdings Kaffee morgens. Ich habe auch angefangen, Kaffee zu trinken. Ich habe schon ganz oft gesagt, ich bin so ein Phasenmensch. Ich muss einfach mal so Phasen durchmachen. Und jetzt gerade habe ich so eine Coffee-to-go-Dre-Tage-Bad-Phase, wo ich mich ein bisschen gehen lasse. Aber es wird nie so richtig cool und nie selbstbewusst. Das ist so mein Ding. Jetzt ist du dran. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich auch angefangen Kaffee zu trinken, ich werde es aber glaube ich wieder lassen, weil es einfach nicht funktioniert. Ich finde es auch so schwer einzusteigen, weil man nicht erstmal das ganze Wissen drauf schaffen muss, was regelmässige Kaffeeträger alles schon haben. Da muss man erstmal aufschauen und schauen, schmeckt der jetzt gut, ist das jetzt ein guter Kaffee, ist genau wie du neulich. Und zum ersten Mal, da kam jemandro und mal rein und meinte, hey, Florentin Stefan, wollt ihr auch was von der besten Kaffeerösterei Kölns haben? Und wir so, yeah, klar, warum nicht? Und dann kam der rein, wir haben den getrunken, vom besten Kaffeeröster Kölns, Deutschlands, whatever, und wir trinken den und denken uns so, ist das jetzt gut oder ist es nicht gut? Tatsächlich, weil man weiss ja auch nicht, bei Kaffee ist ja auch so ein Ding, also ich glaube, ich habe generell Probleme mit Dingen, die unterschiedliche Qualitäten haben. Also gerade bei Alkohol ist es ja so und bei Kaffee ist es so. Es gibt ja guten Wein und schlechten Wein, es gibt guten Kaffee und schlechten Kaffee. Das heißt, immer wenn du Kaffee oder Wein trinkst. Es gibt gutes Marihuana, es gibt schlechtes Marihuana. Ja, ja, auch natürlich, aber ich glaube, da ist der Unterschied nicht so hoch. Das klang aber sehr wissend gerade. Bist du so ein Drogentyp? Also wenn du dann zum Beispiel Kaffee trinkst, bist du etwa so ein Drogentyp? Wenn du dann zum Beispiel Kaffee trinkst, dann weißt du nicht, mag ich einfach nur keinen Kaffee oder ist das jetzt schlechter Kaffee? Und diese Frage kann niemand beantworten, weil du den Geschmack ja auch nicht entwickeln kannst. Und ich glaube, das ist bei vielen Sachen so, zum Beispiel dieser Klassiker, so Alkohol reinkommen, Bier muss man sich erst angewöhnen, dass es einem schmeckt. Das ist,, ist bei allen Sachen so, dass auch der erste Comic, den du gelesen hast, fandest du auch scheiße. Aber dann beim dritten Comic dachtest du dir, okay, gut, das erste Mal, als du einen Podcast gemacht hast, dachte ich mir auch, Stefan Titzel, das führt zu nichts. Aber man muss halt reinkommen. Man muss genießen, auch erst lernen. Und ich glaube, mit Kaffee lasse ich es jetzt. Ich breche diesen Lernungs-Rotest ab und mache es nicht. Apropos, du wolltest noch was sagen. Ich will auch mal was sagen. Nein, ich will ein bisschen auf die Community eingehen, die Community Service-Stiftung. Ja, die haben uns geschrieben, was ich auch einmal schon gesagt habe, die haben uns gesagt, dass der YouTube-Tunnel down ist. Ja, Rom Dom. Wollt ihr das nicht ändern? Aber das Ding ist, wir haben den noch nie gepflegt. Wir wissen, was ein anderer für uns gemacht. Wir wollen jetzt das mal ein für alle mal erklären, ob Ed Edrom Domsey schreibt, wieso seid ihr nicht mehr auf YouTube zu finden? Ist das so eine Art Zielgruppenmanagement-Massnahme? Nein. Es gab anscheinend einen Fan, der für uns einen YouTube-Channel aufgemacht hat, der das Podcast-UFO hieß und unsere Folgen als YouTube-Video hochgeladen hat. Damit haben wir überhaupt nichts zu tun. Wir haben nicht mal mitbekommen, dass... Wir wären auch cooler gewesen, hätten es das YouTube-UFO genannt. Ja, genau, wir haben das YouTube-Ufo, das ist unser offizieller Channel, das YouTube-Ufo. Könnt ihr schon mal direkt abonnieren, wenn ihr Bock habt. Und auf jeden Fall, alle Fragen dazu können wir nur mit einem irritierten, skeptischen Schulterzucken beantworten, weil wir keine Ahnung haben. Wir haben, glaube ich, nicht vor, die Folgen auf YouTube hochzuladen. Allerdings zum Thema Vertriebsweg wird sich in den nächsten Wochen noch eine Überraschung, weil wir eventuell eine neue Form des Vertriebes haben.
Ich sag nur, schaut mal in den Himmel, ob ihr da was lesen könnt.
Ich sag nur, das Logo ist ein bisschen so wie das von Skype und ist ein Konkurrenzprodukt zu Spotify.
Und wenn ihr euch von Spotify melden wollt, dann tut das doch mal bitte, weil wir wollen eigentlich viel lieber zu euch.
Und auf jener Seite sind wir vielleicht auch beizufinden. Also, Stefan Titzel eröffnet neues Lebenskapitel, er erschlägt den grossen Wälzer von Stefan Titzels Leben auf, Staub fliegt überall rum und er liest die erste Zeile, was könnte passieren. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass bei dir sich so eine gewisse Exzentrik eingeschlichen hat, mein Lieber. Gute, gute, gute. Ja, was ich aber sagen! Was meinst du denn damit mit Exzentrik? Ein exotisches Haustier, der Kampffisch. Als nächstes ein exotisches Fortbewegungsmittel. Ganz kurz, werden wir ganz kurz. Erst wenn das alles Projekte, die von meinem armseligen Leben ablenken sollen. Das ist meine, das sagt der Therapeut und das auch ich mir selber. Neben diesen exzentrischen Haustieren, die Stefan Titz in seinem Leben hat, kommt jetzt der nächste Schritt, exzentrisches Fortbewegungsmittel. Bitteschön. Es ist so, ich bin sehr interessiert, ich bin nicht mehr interessiert, fangen wir so an, ich bin nicht mehr interessiert am Laufen. Ich möchte einfach nicht mehr laufen. Ich möchte das Gehen einstellen. Es gibt dir nichts mehr. Ja, es ist so, ich fahre U-Bahn relativ lang und das neue Studio liegt halt wahnsinnig weit weg von dieser U-Bahn-Station. Und man muss sehr lange gehen morgens, da habe ich keine Lust drauf. Ich will einfach wieder ein bisschen ausschlafen können und wieder ein bisschen später los. Und dann bräuchte ich irgendwas, womit ich diesen Weg überbrücken kann. Aber da gibt es doch nichts. Du musst doch laufen. Oder? Es gibt doch keine andere Fortbewegungsmittel als laufen. Lassen wir das altmodische Fahrrad mal beiseite und konzentrieren uns auf die coolen, futuristischen. Ja, ich finde beim Fahrrad fehlt der Comedy-Aspekt. Online-Skates. Du hast diese coole Haltung auf dem Fahrrad, das ist alles mir zu wenig Comedy. Und dann gibt es dieses coole Einrad.
Es gibt ein Rad, wo links und rechts kann man, die sind elektrisch, nennt sich Onewheel oder weiß ich nicht, wenn man das noch nennt, ganz viele verschiedene Namen im Internet jedenfalls. Und du hast rechts und links kannst du deinen Fuss draufstellen, du hast ein großes Rad in der Mitte, lehnst ihn nach vorne, funktioniert wie ein Segway und du kannst dementsprechend dann fahren. Es geht sogar sehr schnell, du kannst aber sämtliche Untergründe fahren. Und ich habe mir das bestellen wollen, aber der Hersteller hat mir relativ schnell zurückgeschrieben, wir verkaufen diese Produkte einfach nicht mehr, as barely people need it. Was so eine perfekte Antwort ist. Ich finde es immer cool, wenn Leute aus diesem PR-Marketing-Sprech rausfallen. Das ist so grossartig. Es ist nicht ausverkauft, es ist nicht zu gut, sondern well, people don't need it. Einfach ganz offen. Ja, das Produkt war nicht so gut, Leute brauchen es nicht, Leute haben Beine. Normalerweise bei Produkten ist ja das Problem, dass die Leute es nicht wollen. Also they don't want it, aber hier they don't need it, sie brauchen es einfach nicht. Sagt der Top-Hersteller dieses Ding. Ein Hersteller hat sich nur auf diese One-Reals konzentriert und er treibt mich zurück, as barely people need it. Ich finde nur aus einem Trauerschein. Barely ist auch geil. Kaum jemand braucht es. Und das ist schon mal ganz geil in der Konzeptphase. Die Leute brauchen es. Wer braucht es denn? Also wer braucht Coca-Cola? Niemand braucht es. Es ist aber gut, dass sie auch komplett den Effort aufgegeben haben, mit gar keinem Ehrgeiz mehr in irgendwas stecken, einfach sagen, nein, wir machen es einfach nicht mehr. Ja, dass sie es zumindest wollen, wenn sie es schon nicht brauchen, aber einfach zu sagen, es braucht man nicht, also auch so dieses Eingeständnis, ja, unser Produkt braucht niemand. Und da hast du dann aufgegeben, oder wie, da hast du deinen exzentrischen Weg aufgegeben. Ich frage mich aber auch, woher dieses Eingeständnis von denen kommt. Vielleicht war es einfach so ein Lost in Translation einfach. Und die wollten mir etwas ganz anderes sagen. Naja, und dann habe ich diesen Hersteller noch mal gecheckt und der stellt etwas anderes her. Der hat sich ja spezialisiert auf etwas, was Leute definitiv brauchen. Und zwar ist es ein Segway ohne, ja gut, wie nennt man das, Stab, ohne diesen Lenkstab, den man in der Hand hält, einfach nur das Board, einfach so ein Hoverboard-ähnliches Gefährt mit zwei Rädern und das ist wahnsinnig cool, ist wahnsinnig schnell und in Deutschland wahnsinnig teuer, aber ich habe, wie gesagt, den Hersteller kontaktiert und habe es von 1800 Euro auf 170 runtergehandelt, weil es wohl das Beste ist, was mir jemals gelungen ist. Weisst du, was ich dazu sage? Fehlkauf! Einfach mal ein improvisierter Fehlkauf-Dschingel, weil diese ganze Story von vorne bis hinten ist einfach die klassische Stefan-Tietze-Origin-Story. Hast du richtig gesagt? Fehlkauf. Nee, das Ding ist aber auch, es war halt relativ seriös bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo mir aufgefallen ist, dass es nicht so ganz seriös ist, als ich Angst bekommen habe nämlich. Und dann kam der Punkt, wo sie mir halt nicht mehr zurückgeschrieben hat. Das waren so kleine Dinge, die mir dann aufgefallen sind.
Zum Beispiel, die hat mir nicht mehr zurückgeschrieben, seitdem ich das Geld überwiesen habe.
Ich musste doppelt so viel Geld überweisen.
Ich musste kommentarweise doch 1.800 Euro überweisen.
Nee, den Rest kriegst du dann später wieder zurück.
So Dinge wie Telefonnummer, war grau unterlegt mit versteckt, also nicht sehbar, Fax versteckt, Adresse versteckt, Name der Firma, gut, versteckt. Schwer auszusprechen. Zu und zu schwer auszusprechen. Ja, mal gucken, was daraus wie geht. Aber es ist halt, ich bin mit dem PayPal Käuferschutz abgesichert, PayPal ihre sichere, zu bezahlen. Und deswegen habe ich eine nicht so viel Angst.
Ich bin sehr viel zuversichtlich, dass man einen exzentrischen Vorbewegungsstil.
Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, lass uns doch mal ein bisschen Psychotherapie spielen.
Warum, woher kommt das?
Ich lebe mich mal kurz auf deine Couch.
Ja, also Herr Titzel, ich habe gemerkt, Sie versuchen in letzter Zeit,
sich selbst zu diesem exzentrischen Hauch zu geben. Sie sind nicht jemand, der nicht mit dem Fahrrad zur Schule kommt, sondern Sie kommen auf diesem komischen Haverboard. Ihr Tandem benutzen Sie kaum noch. Ihr Tandem, wo Sie hinten extra diesen riesigen Teddybären draufgeschnallt haben. Sie machen die Hausaufgaben nicht mehr. Damit es nicht so aussieht, als würden Sie ganz allein durchs Leben gehen. Was ist da passiert? Sie haben sich aus Tennisbällen Schuhe gemacht, auch die benutzen Sie kaum noch. Was ist da los? Warum haben sie immer das Bedürfnis, aus der Reihe zu tanzen? Fühlen sie sich etwas so uninteressant, wo man sagt, ach, das ist der mit dem Segway, das ist der mit dem lustigen halben Basketball auf dem Kopf. USP, ja. Das ist der, der die ganze Zeit mit der C3PO-Maske rumläuft. Ich will so ein bisschen irgendwas, ja nicht USP, so ein paar Dinge, wo man sagt, okay, das ist eher der exzentrische Typ, das ist so der lustige Fortbewegungsmittel-Typ. Weiß nicht, irgendwas, mal gucken, was du da ausstecken. Ich verstehe das ganz genau, ich habe genau das gleiche Bedürfnis und ich habe auch noch kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal gefunden, was mich so wirklich rausfällt. Wahnsinnig schlechte Kleidung, wahnsinnig schlechte Gesichtsbehaarung, wahnsinnig hässliches Gesicht, wahnsinnig fettige Haare, die ohne Frisur da sind, wahnsinnig schlechte musikalische Talente, wahnsinnig lange Fingernägel, wahnsinnig ungeflägte Füße, sehe ich gerade, wahnsinnig seltsamen Kleidungsstil, habe ich schon gesagt, aber ich muss es einfach zweimal nennen, weil es unfassbar furchtbar ist, weil dieser unfassbare Mundgeruch, dieser beißende Mundgeruch. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich, also da sind wir wieder beim Thema Versäumnisse. Also du hast das Gefühl, du hättest versäumt, dir eine eigene Persönlichkeit zu bauen. Und musst das jetzt irgendwie mehr oder weniger forcieren, zu sagen... Nee, es ist auch Teil der Persönlichkeit. Nein, aber da sind wir doch beim Thema Hipster. Also man versucht sich ja immer durch Dinge zu identifizieren, aber es muss ja irgendwie ohne, also es darf kein Effort sagen. Man darf nicht sagen, oh, ich habe mir jetzt diese Tweetjacke gekauft, um extrovertiert auszusehen, um komisch auszusehen. Das unterstelle ich dir ja gerade. Der Hipster möchte ja so aussehen, als hätte er das zufällig im Keller von seinem Opa gefunden.
Und das ist alles nicht konstruiert. Also eine Persönlichkeit darf nicht konstruiert sein. Der Hipster möchte ja so aussehen, als wäre das alles zufällig, als hätte er das zufällig im Keller von seinem Opa gefunden.
Und das ist alles nicht konstruiert. Also eine Persönlichkeit darf nicht konstruiert sein. Aber ich gebe nicht so viel Geld aus, um mir was zu konstruieren, einfach Bock auf diesem Ding rumzufahren. Also ich glaube, das ist so tief in meinem Herzen, wünsche ich mir dieses Gerät, dass ich nicht glaube, das ist Teil der Konstruktion. Aber hast du da wirklich Bock drauf oder ist es nur ein vorgeschobenes Interesse, um irgendwie rauszustechen? Damit Leute sagen, oh du bist interessant, damit falls du mal irgendwie ein junges Mädchen auf der Strasse triffst, dass du dann mit ihr was zu reden hast, zu sagen, hey, oh das ist ja interessant, du bist ja ein cooler Typ, du hast ja so dieses komische Fortbewegungsmittel. So wird das Gespräch nicht laufen, es wird eher so laufen wie, oh mein Gott, dein Gesicht ist weg, du bist in diesen LKW einfach reingefahren, weil du nicht stoppen konntest auf dein seltsamen Free-Pants-Free-Segway-Thing. Warum trägst du keinen Helm, warum kriegst du keine Shona in der ersten Woche, wo du so ein Ding fährst. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, wir bewegen uns ja hier im Thema Fortbewegungsmittel. Und Fortbewegungsmittel wurden schon immer zu einem einzigen Zweck. Nee, hör mal jetzt auf, ich hab ja keine Lust mehr drauf. Nein, warte, Fortbewegungsmittel wurden immer zu einem einzigen Zweck konstruiert, und zwar um Frauen aufzureissen. Man kauft sich ein Auto, ein cooles Auto primär, um damit Frauen abzuschleppen. Ich kann dir nicht glauben, dass das nicht zumindest ein gewisser kleiner Teil dieser Kaufentscheidung auch ist, dass du besser bei Frauen ankommen möchtest. Man muss dazu sagen, dass diese Dinge wahnsinnig uncool aussehen. Man sieht darauf wahnsinnig unattraktiv aus, weil man die ganze Zeit diese wartende Haltung einnimmt. Also man ist nicht wie auf dem Fahrrad und bewegt sich dabei und trampelt oder wie ein Jogger, der die Arme so hochnimmt, der die Arme so hochnimmt und immer so wackelt und so. Man ist einfach in so einer wartenden, abwartenden Haltung, die Arme hängen einfach so herab an einem Körper. Die hängenden Arme sind das grösste Problem. Und irgendwann ist man einfach da. Man steht plötzlich an einem Ort und dann steht man die ganze Zeit und plötzlich ist man an seinem Ziel. Das ist uncool. Man wartet durch die Gegend, man wartet, das ist der einzige, man wartet halt so lange, bis man am Ziel ist und man macht nichts. Man steht und irgendwann ist man da. Ja, aber diese Erkenntnis hatte ich auch, weil ich bin nämlich immer Snowblades gefahren. Das sind so ganz kurze Ski, die sehr einfach sind zu fahren. Und ich dachte mir, ich wäre total der coole Typ. Allerdings, du hast ja nicht irgendwie beim Skifahren Stöcke in der Hand oder sowas, sondern du stehst einfach nur da. Und ich habe mal aus dem Lift jemand anders gesehen, der Snowblades gefahren ist, und der sah halt einfach so aus, als steht er einfach kerzengerade und fährt einfach so den Berg runter. Mit einem völlig starren Gesicht, völlig ausdruckslos, wie es in einem Schaufensterboden ist. Wo das Gesicht auch sagt, nee, das mache ich nie wieder. Ja, man muss auch die Körpersprache, man muss irgendwie zumindest in die Hocke gehen oder so die Arme einfach vorne nehmen und so eine cool Pose haben. Wenn du das nicht hast, das wirkt einfach seltsam. Ich bin auch schon sehr gross. Also die Bewegung ohne Dynamik, kann man es vielleicht sagen. Ich bin ja so schon sehr gross und sehr lulatschig. Ja, ich bin ja noch ein Stück grösser. Ja, ich bin noch ein Stück grösser, noch 20 cm grösser. Und es wird nicht dazu beitragen, dass irgendwie ich attraktiver werde und dass Frauen mich ansprechen, ausser wenn ich mal wieder irgendwie einen schweren Verkehrsunfall konstruiert habe, weil ich auf diesem Ding halt rumgefahren bin. Was muss man dazu sagen, keine Strassenerlaubnis hat in Deutschland. Aber ein Stefan Titzel braucht keine Strassenerlaubnis. Braucht keine Strassenerlaubnis, richtig. Sehen Sie die Strassenverkehrsordnung? Die liegt da hinten im Mülleimer. Im Mülleimer. Zum Thema Versäumnisse. Ja. Und zwar habe ich damals in der Folge, wo du ein Stand-up gemacht hast, habe ich gesagt, ich werde in der nächsten Folge, werde ich das Ganze reviewen und sagen, das hat mir gefallen, ich werde Tipps dazu geben, ich werde sagen, was mir schon gefallen hat, was nicht funktioniert hat in meiner Meinung nach. Und das habe ich versäumt, einfach. Und das wollte ich nur sagen. Ich wollte es nicht jetzt machen, ich wollte es einfach nochmal sagen. Nee, ich wollte es machen gerne. Wollen wir kurz drüber reden nochmal? Ernsthaft? Ja, ich habe mir ein bisschen was vorbereitet. Ja, dann lass mich kurz, dann bin ich kurz gleich wieder da. Was macht er? Er hat es gehört und ist rausgegangen plötzlich. Weinend, und jetzt steht er vor der Tür und schreit in seinem Kissen. Ich sehe gerade, ich habe jetzt einen blanken Blick auf Florentins Kinderzimmer. Und ich kann nicht so viel sagen, es steht ein iMac, ein grosser 27 Zoll iMac da, man denkt, cooler Typ, hey, der, wow, er gibt Geld aus für technische Sachen, aber direkt dahinter ist halt das Schwert. Das macht viel kaputt. Direkt dahinter, direkt im Blickfeld des IMAX zeigt einem das Schwert. Okay, er hat mich geirrt. Davor ist eine Art Jacke zusammengeknüllt, davor ist der Stuhl, auf dem er sich befindet, zu sehen. Und jetzt ist er wieder da. Jetzt kommt er wieder. Okay, los geht's. Was musstest du genau jetzt machen? Ich musste ganz kurz nach dem Rechten sehen, um es so allgemein wie möglich zu halten. Ich finde es auch toll, weißt du, bei dem Thema Versäumnisse dachte ich mir am Anfang, das wird eine richtig emotionale Folge. Was haben wir in unserer Jugend verpasst? Bereuen wir es, dass wir erst seit zwei Wochen überhaupt mit Frauen anfangen, Kontakt zu haben? Was bereuen wir? Ich dachte, es wird so nicht die emotionale, ernste Folge. Und was passiert? Stefan Titzel dreht das Thema Knallhart um in, ich kritisiere Florentin Wilts Comedy-Auftritt. Ja, das ist auch so. Okay, gut, dann liegt los, auf geht's. Die Leute können sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, sollen wir den nochmal einspielen jetzt? Nein. Wir sind jetzt gerade relativ gleich unterschiedlich. Also ich glaube, wir sind jetzt gerade relativ gleich so, aber unsere Vergangenheit war nicht unbedingt gleich.
Also können wir gleich nochmal gerne noch zurück zu sprechen
kommen. Wir haben andere Sachen versorgt, glaube ich.
Also ganz kurz, in der Podcast-Folge
Maxi Stettenbauer, ganz am Ende,
in den letzten zehn Minuten könnt ihr meinen
ersten Versuch eines Stand-up-Auftritts
hören. Ich habe fünf Minuten geschrieben und
Stefan Titzel kritisiert jetzt,
vier Folgen später. Geil. Ich habe es versäumt halt, wie gesagt, aber das ist das Thema der Sendung. Ich wollte eigentlich so ein lockerflöckiges Gespräch mit dir darüber aufbauen. Und zwar finde ich, dein Opener war ja nicht vorhanden. Also es kam, du wolltest halt auf diese Frauenfußballthematik zu sprechen kommen, Blindenfußball, Entschuldigung, aber liegt ja sehr beinahe beieinander, oder? Bau! Du wolltest dann relativ schnell auf diese Blindenthematik zu sprechen kommen, was natürlich ein sehr schwieriges Setting ist, um es als Opener direkt zu etablieren. Und deswegen hast du halt den ersten Satz... Das stimmt, ich hatte weder einen Opener noch einen Closer, das habe ich aber davor auch gesagt. Ich habe kurz bevor ich angefangen genuschelt, ich habe keinen Anfang, keinen Ende.
Deswegen dachte ich, ich hätte das damit auch ganz gut erledigt.
Jeder erste Buchstabe deiner Gags ergeben insgesamt zusammen, ich habe keinen Opener und keinen Erinner.
Ich habe tatsächlich hier den Setup in Textform vor mir, also ich kann auf alles nochmal genau eingehen.
Wie gesagt, du brauchst sehr lange, um auf eine okaye Geschichte einzugehen, da haust du dann gute Gags raus und dann kommt plötzlich dieses Spiel gegen sieben zu null aus. Aber who cares, also diese Blindenfußball-Thematik, die nimmst du gut auseinander, da bist du dann ein sehr feiner Observational Comedian und du gehst richtig ins Detail und dann denkt man, wow, was passiert jetzt und dann sagst du komische Details, haust du manchmal raus, die du glaube ich einfach nicht brauchst.
Okay, nehme ich raus. Ich dachte, die Idee ist, dass man so ein bisschen aufbaut, dass das Spiel schlecht lief und deswegen der Trainer nochmal richtig kritisch übt.
Dann sagt das aber dann, sagt das direkt. Aber muss kann raus.
Dann fängst du auch drauf, da hinzuleiten auf diese Drücker-Anekdote, habe ich sie mal genannt, wo wo du über einen Ampel-Drücker sprichst. Dies aber finde ich relativ ziellos und schwach. Okay. Das Subway-Ding finde ich auch relativ wirr und das Blutel-Ding auch. Also der Mittelteil finde ich komplett, da hast du zwar immer mal gute Gags da drin, aber ich finde, du musst dir überlegen, das ist eine grundsätzliche Frage, erzählt man Gags nacheinander und ist dann fertig mit dem Thema oder will man halt der observational Louis C. K. Comedian sein oder Jerry Seinfeld, der halt wirklich dann ein Thema komplett ausbringt und komplett auf alle Facetten des Themas eingeht und dann fängt man ja auch an, über Dinge zu sprechen, über die noch nie jemand anders vorgesprochen hat oder ob du einfach einen Gag machen willst. Und wenn du einen Gag machen willst, wo du meinst, das Thema trägt dadurch,
und das Thema ist quasi relevant genug, allein weil der Gag da drin ist,
der eine gute Gag, dann kann man das so machen.
Ich glaube, es sollte eine Mischung sein.
Also ich habe versucht, irgendeine einzelne Dinge zu bauen, aber halt auch die,
vor allem ist es halt schwierig, weil ich beschreibe halt diesen Ampeldrücker erstmal lange
und ich dachte, das ist so ein Ding, wo ich den Zuschauer vielleicht mit reinkriege, weil ich glaube, ich dachte zumindest, das wäre ein Phänomen, das viele Leute kennen, dass wenn sie eben, also auch dieses ein bisschen, es gibt immer einen Deppen der, ja, eine Gruppe Leute warten an der Ampel und es gibt immer einen Trottel, der rumdrückt, obwohl es gar nichts zu drücken gibt. Da dachte ich schon mal, okay, das ist so ein Pfad, auf den folgen mir die Leute. Ein Depp in der Gruppe und vielleicht kennen das auch Leute, dass sie auch selber schon mal dieser Depp waren oder dass sie das schon mal gesehen haben. Und dadurch dachte mir das bei vielen Leuten so ein Ah ja, kenne ich Moment angeht. Und dann beschreibt man eben ein bisschen, wie er da rumdrückt, ohne dass es was bringt. Und die Pointe ist dann, er drückt da rum, obwohl es überhaupt nicht mal einen Knopf gibt, auf den man rumdrücken kann, genauso wie mein erstes Mal lief. So, das ist dann die Pointe, die natürlich fast ein bisschen falsch rum ist, weil man wahrscheinlich das gar nicht so direkt verbindet, aber es ist halt einfach die... Es ist nicht so wirklich, es liegt nicht so wirklich nah, dass man... Man müsste es vielleicht andersrum machen, von wegen, hey, wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie mein erstes Mal war, im Grunde so wie dieser Ampeldinger, man drückt da rum, obwohl es da nicht mal einen Knopf gibt. So, dann wird es vielleicht ein bisschen, es ist so schon relativ weit entfernt, weil man erstes Mal sich mit rumdrücken und auf Knopfdrücken verbinden würde. Ja, für den Gag ist es ja nicht schlecht, dass es da sehr weit weg ist, eigentlich, aber ich finde, der ist noch nicht so ganz gerade, da muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen dann feilen. Aber ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie man das reparieren könnte, weil es halt, ja, weiß ich nicht. Aber ja. Dann fängst du halt wieder an, über die Tiere irgendwann zu sprechen, die Unfälle verursachen, was wirklich ein guter Clause auch wäre. Also diese Tiere, die durch Zufall irgendwie einen Zug entgleisen lassen, bringen mich zum Lachen. Und dadurch die Statistik von ihrer Tierart versauen. Also dass man sagt, Schildkröten töten im Jahr XY Menschen, aber dass man eine dusselige Schildkröte einen Zug entgleisen hat lassen und dadurch in diesem Jahr alle Schildkröten total schlecht errschen. Ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass Leute, die das gerade hören und das nicht überskippt haben, auch schon den Stand abgehört haben. Hätte man vorher vielleicht dazusagen können, aber wir haben uns bewusst für die schlechtere Version entschieden. Ja, aber sonst hat es mir ganz gut gefallen. Das war meine Review, meine kurze. Es ist ja tatsächlich so. Ja, danke schön. Man kann ja mal sagen, dass wir... Podcast-Ufo Stand-Up-Review. Man kann ja mal sagen, dass Stefan und ich uns jetzt endlich dazu entschlossen haben, den ersten Schritt zu gehen, unser erstes Mal gemeinsam zu haben. Und zwar werden wir das erste Mal ein Live-On-Stage-Stand-Up aufgetan. Wir haben unsere ersten fünf Minuten Slots, Stage Time, in Köln, in einem Comedy Club. Am? Nein, das erste Mal verraten wir noch nicht. Wir verraten das vierte Mal. Aber wollen wir da nicht gleich ein Hörertreffen draus machen? Können wir doch eigentlich direkt machen. Nein, nein, nein. Aber ich will, wenn ich scheitern will, dann vor meinen Hörern. Vor denen scheitere ich eh schon jede Woche, deswegen, da bin ich es gewohnt, das ist meine Comfortzone, scheitern kann ich, das ist kein Problem. Am 26.11. um, weiss ich noch nicht wie viel Uhr, 11? Echt, erst so spät? Sind wir im Comedy Club, im Boing Comedy Club, boing, ist mir immer peinlich, wenn ich das sagen muss, weil es ist echt ein uncooler Name.
Uncooler Name.
Ich bin auf diesem Club aufmerksam geworden. Ich war zum ersten Mal da, das war auch ganz cool.
Und beim zweiten Mal war ich dann da, weil ein Kumpel von mir, der zum ersten Mal seine fünf Minuten hatte.
Und das war echt furchtbar. Also das hat mich echt eine Woche lang runtergezogen, dieser Abend, wo ich mir dachte, das willst du nicht, der willst du nicht auftreten.
Aber das ist ja auch dann, das ist immer so was, wo man sich dann auch denkt, ist das ein bisschen zu blauäugig, das ist ein bisschen zu naiv, die Denke, man sollte es eigentlich trotzdem machen.
Wenn man denkt, man kann das auch und man könnte vielleicht ein bisschen was dafür tun, dass es gut wird.
Ja, ich bin vor allem ganz froh, dass wir jetzt diesen Termin haben, der ist unausweichlich und wir wissen, dass wir beide an dem Tag wahrscheinlich versagen werden.
Und dann und wir ein bisschen was dafür tun, dass es gut wird. Ja, ich bin vor allem ganz froh, dass wir jetzt diesen Termin haben, der ist unausweichlich und wir wissen, dass wir beide an dem Tag wahrscheinlich versagen werden und da haben wir jetzt lange Zeit, uns darauf vorzubereiten und ich habe schon mal versagt beim Stand-up, deswegen ist das auch kein Problem für mich. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf deinen tatsächlich. Ich habe echt vor ein Experiment zu machen, finde ich vielleicht nicht so schlecht, mal was ganz Absurdes zu machen, zum Beispiel ein Stand-up, der in einem anderen Kosmos spielt, wie zum Beispiel Star Wars oder Harry Potter. Du tust so, als wärst du ein Stand-Up-Comedian in Star Wars Welt. Genau, ein Stand-Up, der nicht in der heutigen, in dieser Welt, in der wir leben, spielt, weil hier wurde ja schon vieles gemacht, viele Gags wurden schon gemacht in der heutigen Welt, Dinge laufen schief, es wurden Männer, Frauen und so. Warum nicht mal ein Stand-Up-Programm
in Star Wars-Kosmos zu machen
und sich über lustige
Teilfighter aufzuregen? Warum sind die
eigentlich so geformt? Warum sind die
eigentlich haarförmig?
Das wird auch etwa
die Reaktion sein, die ich erwarte.
Aber irgendwie sowas Experimentelles
werde ich dann wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Also statt fetten Witze machst du dann Jabba the Hutt Witze. Genau. Statt Rainer Carlmund benutzt man immer Jabba the Hutt. Da kann man eins zu eins austauschen. Das ist immer noch mega schlecht, der Gag, aber es ist halt noch nie gehört. Statt Sebastian Hediaty machst du einfach Chewbacca. Relativ einfach. Qui-Gon Jinn. Vielleicht hat er was mit Kindern. Qui-Gon Jinn ist ja Pedo, oder was? I don't know. Wer ist eigentlich der Star-Wars-Pedo? Es gibt doch in jedem Universum Pedo. Bei Herr der
Ringe ist es Tom Bombardier, wer ist es bei Star-Wars?
Eindeutig Obi-Wan Kenobi am Ende. Ben Kenobi, Entschuldigung.
Ach so, Ben...
Ben Kenobi, klar, wie der sich an den jungen Luke ran schmeißt.
Bei Harry Potter ist es der Hausmeister und Hagrid natürlich.
Und Dumbledore, der schwul ist.
Und Dumbledore, ja.
Das war auch der strangeste Move der aller Geschichtenerzähler, oder? Das war einfach vier Jahre nach Abschluss der Geschichte so. Übrigens, der eine war schwul ist. Und Dumbledore, ja, das war auch der strangeste Move der aller Geschichtenerzähler,
oder? Das war einfach vier Jahre nach Abschluss der
Geschichte so, übrigens, der eine war schwul.
Okay,
aber so, alles klar.
Die Podcast-Uvo-Scheinblatt ist wieder
bei Jula gekommen. Ja, okay, dann
schnagel ich die mal auf ein neues Storyfest, du hast nämlich
erzählt, dass du eine tolle Hemdanekdote hast.
Hau die doch mal raus, du Arschloch. Nee, will ich jetzt nicht. Ich würde gerne, ist das nicht krass, Leute, Wissenschaftsfreak, Wissenschaftsleute haben krass Sachen rausgefunden, Wasser ist auf dem Mars. Warum bist du eigentlich kein Weltallfreak? Guck mal, das Poster da hinter mir, das Poster hinter mir. Ich interessiere mich nur für Pluto, der Rest ist mir egal, mit Pluto kann ich mich identifizieren, das ist der ausgestossene Planet, der trotzdem noch jeden Tag mit um die Sonne kreist, aber er gehört offiziell nicht mehr dazu. Damit kann ich mich gut identifizieren. Mit dem Mars und diesen ganzen coolen Planeten, das ist nichts für mich. Das sind so die Insider-Planeten, das mag ich nicht. Fühl mich mal ein bisschen in deinem Zimmer rum. Mal ein bisschen so follow me around. Also, wir haben hier meinen Schreibtisch, der eigentlich kein Schreibtisch ist, sondern mehr eine Ablage einfach.
Du siehst, da die Kleidung liegt drauf. Ich habe mal einen Screenshot gemacht für euch. Hier ist das Fenster. Das ist das Fenster. Wo kann man da rausgucken? Sieht man irgendwas aus Berlin, in der Sehenswünsche? Oh, tatsächlich ist hier, warte mal, ich kann hier, muss hier leider ein bisschen was abstecken, ich kann das leider nicht abstecken, sonst ist das Mikrofon weg. Aber man kann hier tatsächlich sehen, in einem Event... Ne, sieht man nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist tatsächlich nebenan gerade eine Party, hier ist so eine Eventhalle. Und da sieht man die bunten Lichter und die Musik hört man auch ein bisschen im Hintergrund. Deswegen da ist immer Party nebenan, was tatsächlich ein schöner Kontrast ist zu meinem Leben, in dem überhaupt nichts passiert, was immer ganz schön ist, dass man raus sieht und man sieht die Partys.
Und das ist ja tatsächlich auch wieder Thema Versäumnisse. Ich habe jetzt letztes Mal einen Ausflug in das Berliner Nachtleben gemacht, weil ich ziehe wahrscheinlich bald weg aus Berlin und dachte mir so Berlin... Und zwar nach Köln oder nach Amerika in unser geiles neues Haus, was wir für 200 Euro bekommen haben. Claire Danes, die Hauptdarstellerin von Homeland, war ja letztens bei Ellen DeGeneres und hat erzählt, wie sie ja in Berlin die Staffel Homeland gedreht hat. Und da war sie im Berghain und sie hat erzählt, so wie das Berghain ist und hat so versucht, das Berghain dem amerikanischen Publikum zu erklären, so das ist riesengroß und es gibt Eis und alle tanzen nackt und so und diese krasse Berliner Club-Erfahrung. Ist das denn so eigentlich? Ich weiß nichts davon, ich weiß echt, das ist also Mythos. Ja und deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt auch, okay, ich muss mich auch ein bisschen in diese in diese Berliner Klub-Erfahrung. Ist das denn so eigentlich? Ich weiß nichts davon, ich weiß echt. Ja, und deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt auch, okay, ich muss mich auch ein bisschen in diese Berliner Klubszene hineinschmeissen. Und ich merke aber wirklich immer sofort, es ist überhaupt nichts für mich. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Aber das ist so ein bisschen Versäumnis. Man wünscht sich, man wäre so ein cooler Typ, der auf Partys geht und in den Clubs irgendwie Frauen abschleppt und da irgendwie total drin ist und es total versteht. Aber letztendlich funktioniert es einfach nicht. Du denkst dir dann, okay, vielleicht die Frau gefällt mir, aber ich würde mich gerne mit ihr unterhalten, aber es ist einfach wahnsinnig laut. Und dann sagt dein Freund, wenn du auf einer Tanzfläche mit jemandem reden willst, dann mach folgendes, dann geh zu denen hin und steck ihnen so deinen Finger halb ins Ohr, damit sie die Musik nicht mehr hören kann, und dann kannst du gut mit denen reden. Da gibt es so eine Technik, dass man irgendwie so diesen Ohrlappen, also dieses Innere, was da so ein bisschen ins Ohr reinragt, dass man den so reindrückt und dadurch, dass man nichts mehr hört, und dann kann man irgendwie so besser mit jemandem reden, weil man die Musik, die Bässe so ein bisschen ausgefiltert hat. Und das ist halt mega awkward. Das sind immer noch, auch wenn es ein schönes Mädchen ist, das ist einfach ein fremder Mensch, dem du den Finger ins Ohr stehst. Ja, und vor allem ist es halt einfach mal acht Comfortzone-Level mir, halt so von wegen, eine Frau anzusprechen ist schon schwierig, aber direkt zu ihr hinzugehen, sie anzufassen und dann noch wirklich massiv in ihre Privatsphäre einzudringen, indem du den Finger ins Ohr steckst. Oder wurde das geprankt? Es kann auch gut ein Prank sein, tatsächlich. Komm, wir gehen und abend mal mit Florentin feiern und dann sagen wir, der muss Frauen die ganze Zeit den Finger ins Ohr stecken, damit er sie anspricht. Ja, das ist auch mega unangenehm einfach. Und das ist tatsächlich, weil diese ganze Welt, du kannst ja mit Frauen nicht reden auf der Tanzfläche, das heißt, dein Ziel ist es, die Frau abzuschleppen in wenigen kurzen, prägnanten Sätzen, die du ihr irgendwie ins Ohr brüllen kannst. Das heißt, es ist genau, das geht in meiner Strategie, dass ich einfach Frauen weichlabere und einfach so lange auf sie einziehe, die irgendwann einfach keine Lust mehr mehr haben. Das heißt, es funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Ja genau, vor allem, ich weiß noch nicht, was sind das dann für prägnante Triggersätze, die man Frauen ins Ohr brüllen kann, damit man dann irgendwie im Darkroom verschwindet oder was auch immer, was auch immer der nächste Level ist, was ja auch immer so ein Problem ist, wo führt das Ganze hin, also ganz schrecklich. Aber da sind wir beim Thema Versäumnis, es gibt gibt Dinge, die man mal gemacht haben muss, irgendwann muss man aber auch feststellen, das ist einfach nichts für mich. Kriminalität und Clubleben ist einfach nichts für mich. Ich finde es gut, wie reflektiert wir sind. Wir wissen doch, warum viel schiefläuft, wir können es so nicht ändern. Viele Leute wissen nicht, was schief wird in ihrem Leben und ändern deshalb nichts, wir wissen es, können es aber nicht ändern. Das ist so ein bisschen das Ding. Und wieder mal sind wir am Ende so eine Selbstmitleidschiene eingeschlagen, wo ihr uns dann vielleicht wieder therapieren könnt in den Kommentaren. Ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen, wenn da wieder steht. Ja genau, schreibt mal Therapie-Kommentare, das würde mich jetzt echt... Schreibt mal ein bisschen was, was uns aufbaut. Neulich wurde ich wieder auf Twitter angegangen von euch, dass ein Tweet nicht so ganz gut war. Ich meine, es hilft mir auch nicht, jetzt nicht jede Woche mich hinzusetzen und Grandios abzuliefern. Nein, es war ja nur eine einzelne Person. Die Person war schon... Er weiß, wer gemeint ist. Nicht wahr, Marius? Du musst machen. Vielen Dank für diese Folge, Florentin. Vielen Dank, dass du wieder dabei warst, dass du dich wieder zu mir gesetzt hast. Immer gerne. Ja, vielen Dank auch an Stefan Titzel für seine fantastischen Einwürfe hin und wieder. Was ist das denn für ein scheiß Abgang? Nein, du brichst mich völlig vernünftig ab. Du brichst mich völlig ab, wie ich es verdient habe heute. Stefan Titzel, meine Damen und Herren! Und freut euch auf eine nächste Folge, die wird fantastisch, denn wir haben einen fantastischen Gast. Wir haben sehr viel Angst vor diesem Gast und wir versuchen uns bestmöglich darauf vorzubereiten, damit das nicht wieder eine Gastkatastrophe-Folge wird. Deswegen bleibt dran und hört, wenn euch die Folge nicht so gut gefallen hat, die abonniert jetzt noch nicht, sondern sagt, ich höre mir zumindest noch mal die nächste Folge an. Die wird, glaube ich, ein bisschen interessanter. Ja, interessant. Es ist ein schmaler Grad, den müssen wir finden. Ich bin zuversichtlich. Wir sind gut vorbereitet. Alles klar. Macht's gut. Flotin, highfifen wir uns nochmal virtuell. Ciao.
Und dann geht's los und dann heben wir wieder ab.
Macht's gut.